yo what's up everybody prestige man
Luigi back inside of the witcher 3 and i
have a new method to get infinite XP
since my old method the Drowned method
has been patched this message method is
going to vow involve the Cyclops you see
here he's a level 30 cyclops so he is
probably going to be for a higher level
XP this is gonna be helpful for when
you're high low higher level and you
want to be at a higher level XP because
obviously the drama method didn't even
work for people that were ads it didn't
be even before it was passed you didn't
work for people that were at super high
XP so there is this Cyclops as you see
here and you solve it you can see the XP
gains and I check that a few times for
the video there's an all show the
location of this on the map later in the
video it's on the very e what east coast
of skill eage south of the whale
graveyard there's a guarded treasure and
a place of power here as well I'll show
you that as well the gut the guard
treasure is actually Richard Gere it's
in Angus enhance key or something I
don't have it in the video but I show
you where the chests are it's right next
to this but you can see the method is go
kill the Cyclops I usually like using a
lot of my bombs because those are I'm
able to get a lot of damage out from a
safe distance you're going to want to
use switch kill the Cyclops you can
probably meditate right in that circle
but then I usually head out to meditate
a few feet away I meditate for an hour
and then the Cyclops will spawn you
getting some alright loop for some
crafting not sure what crafting recipes
use the loot you get from Cyclops's but
you guys soon as that stuff the main
thing you want to do is do this for XP
you can see in this video i think in
level 34 and I'm getting like 44 XP per
kill on him so and like the level cap
I've seen is around level 36 I'm at
level 30 i am love 34 i'm at level 36
right now and i did I don't think I'm
going to level up until they come out
with like new game+ or something but so
this is this this method will get you
close to basically the practical level
cap in this game I of like a first
playthrough because once you start
getting too high level then everything
you kill just starts giving you
one XP since CD CD Projekt RED actually
has implemented some things to discredit
over leveling which was a problem in
this game especially going through the
storyline I'm like I was a little over
level some of my story stuff and I'm
over loved for some missions but that's
because i did my playthrough before they
did the patch and you see it is actually
really easy to fall off the side there
and you saw i almost died so be careful
on the side I I fell off of multiple
times while doing this thing but yeah so
this side club is going to be here and
every time you wait he's going to
respawn after killing him it i just
checked it before I recorded this i
literally just went on to Witcher 3 and
wrote fast travel to skill guy rode my
horse to the Cyclops and killed them a
few times to make sure is to working and
it is it is don't worry unless they come
out with a patch like just at the worst
time when this video goes out it should
work for everyone I'm playing on PC
however usually pc gets passed before
consoles the console you should also be
good to do this it is it he is a big
enemy to kill however he will give you
more XP the lower level you are and you
see I'm four levels above them and i'm
still getting forward exp for kill if
for some reason you want to get to a
specific level there's it on the map if
you want to get to a specific level that
one of the higher levels this will let
you get and you can see it's right it is
right on the coast kind of like in the
middle of the map you just follow the
road on the side of Scalia and you will
find it it's pretty easy to spot it's
like the only structure between the
whale graveyard and a town south of it
and here I go inside inside just go over
and climb up these things and there's a
place of power and there's a two there
too like pretty high quality chests and
they have a good amount of Witcher gear
which is actually really cool since the
finding which agree gear is pretty great
I already looted them um because I made
the video after I explored this place
and I found the exploit and I do
actually i was i was told about this
exploit i won my subscribers and I I
can't recall the subscribers name but
hopefully I'll put an annotation and
give credit to that guy since he told me
about the Cyclops XP thing and I
wouldn't have known about it actually I
did I find it I i think i think i found
with help from him and then also just
exploring the game like I didn't go out
looking for this too much but I I
definitely yeah I found it as though so
thank you to that guy since it obviously
this is a way to get XP so you guys
that's basically gonna be the video i do
have a lot of Witcher 3 content so if
you like that stuff take a look at
subscribing to my channel and looking at
the rest of the videos you see I fell
off here again I think I try to get jump
up but since you can't oh I actually get
up I get up since I get out of combat is
pretty good but yeah so I have a lot of
which with you on like on which is three
content on my channel so check that out
if you want some more money guys and XP
guides and just cool stuff in the game
so hope you've enjoyed this video and
I'll see you all later peace out